dans ce livre vous parlez de vous
expliquer que l'extrême droite que vous
appelez le néofascisme est sur le point
de gagner l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que ça fait pas 20 ans justement
qu'on nous répète cela indéfiniment que
l'extrême droite est sur le point de
gagner l'élection présidentielle
depuis 2002 quasiment à chaque élection
on nous fait le coup est ce que est ce
que ça n'est pas une erreur qui se
répète encore une fois en parlant de la
prochaine élection présidentielle
non mais d'abord c'est la celle inverse
moi je me souviens très bien je faisais
un débat avec alain duhamel à la
télévision il ya 30 ans 40 ans et alain
duhamel et il était d'accord avec tous
les éditorialistes l'extrême droite en
france ne peut pas faire plus de 2% et à
30 ans le 19 mai en demi à partenord les
rats les terrains verts c'est justement
ils n'ont pas vu que qu'il y avait des
racines de déco objectif qui pouvait
provoquer des phénomènes de monter
l'extrême droite d'autre part je vous
dis que je pars de néo fasciste parce
que pour moi le néo fasciste et pas
l'extrême droite c'est une erreur
considérable de d'assimiler néo fascisme
et crée boîte l'extrême droite c'est
quelque chose de particulier c'est à la
droite de la droite c'est le pétainisme
c'est le
c'est contre révolutionnaire c'est
charles maurras et enfin que celle le la
spécificité du fascisme est aujourd'hui
du néofascisme notamment à néofasciste
de jolis peut pas ressembler au fascisme
il dit hier
évidemment mais la spécificité de ce que
japonais néo fasciste c'est la
convergence extrême gauche extrême
droite vous faut toujours le camp en 24
22 ou 23 ou 24 du souligna le congrès
fasciste la création du parti fasciste
italien par mussolini
messieurs les libyens d'extrême gauche
socialiste dans ce congrès c'est
extraordinaire faut l'étudier ce congrès
vous avez des anarcho syndicalistes
d'extrême gauche
vous avez des représentants de ce qu'on
appelait la gauche révolutionnaire et
puis vous avez des réacs en effet vous
avez des royalistes vous avez des
ultranationalistes gayraud qui se sont
radicalisées pendant la guerre et c'est
cette convergence là on n'avait jamais
vu ses spécificités qu'à liège où il ya
eu en italie récemment eu le monde a cru
voir sept nouveaux de nouveau cette
convergence avec l'alliance entre le
parti cinq étoiles oui mais la ligue du
nord essaie ça n'a pas duré longtemps
mais en france on l'a toujours pas vu là
ça ne peut pas marcher parce que c'est
une alliance et qu'un parti libertaire
est évident qu'une alliance entre une
extrême droite autoritaire et à parti
libertaire c'est totalement absurde en
revanche je prends l'exemple du connu
qu'au congrès
fasciste de mussolini vous avez un autre
énorme genre en plus j'en ai parlé à
marine le pen et elle était très
intéressant fin le connaissais très bien
cette histoire c'est qu'on oublie
toujours un des créateurs du parti nazi
de hitler ses deux frères qui s'appelle
les frères strasser c'est eux qui
étaient les idéologues du mouvement et
les fraîches traceur c'est des vrais
socialistes c'est à dire c'est vraiment
le fascisme au vrai sens du terme c'est
à dire à la fois réactionnaire par
certains aspects antilles et en même
temps réellement anticapitaliste
antibourgeois etc mais simplement vous
savez ce qui était arrivé à strass r non
tu vas hitler l'a fait assassiner lors
de la nuit des longs couteaux
oui l'autre est bardé faire que ça ne
dure pas à un moment la fraction
droitière élimine l'infraction gauchiste
mais à l'origine le fasciste c'est
vraiment cette convergence entre extrême
droite et extrême gauche mais je n'ai
pas l'extrême droite
[Musique]